[Music]
Theresa May has now announced that she's
going to be stepping down as prime
minister so who is gonna succeed her
about 13 people perhaps even more put
their names forward the election to be
leader of the Conservative Party is in
two stages the first stage is with the
MPs
the MPs produce a shortlist of two
candidates then you go to the country to
party members and then they will vote on
who they want to be the leader and
that's interesting because the sort of
thing that the MPs are looking for may
be very different from sort of thing
that the members are looking for the MPs
will probably look for somebody who's
sensible saying can appeal to the whole
country and the members are very very
strongly Pro brexit so Boris Johnson is
in some ways the man to beat and people
have very strong opinions about him
people who like him really like him
people who dislike him really dislike
him he's had a very colorful private
life to put it very politely he's a bit
of a trump figure but he's got talent
he's got charisma so he's able to reach
the parts of the populace that most
tourists can't can't reach
he will remould the Conservative Party
as a pro brexit nationalist populist
party that may just be the sort of party
of the country wants to vote for Michael
Gove is a very innovative thinker he's
the cleverest of the lot intellectually
he's disliked by the brexit ears because
he's thought to have betrayed them he's
disliked by Boris Johnson because he
nice Boris Johnson in the back so he's
not trusted by everybody but he's a very
significant candidate he's also been
very good at running departments he's
run the Department of the Environment
extremely well he was a very innovative
Secretary of State for Education he's a
thinker and he's thought above all about
the crisis of capitalism and about how
we bring the nation back together after
the financial crisis
Jeremy Hunt has a sort of Tony Blair
quality in the sense that his eloquent
is very fast on his feet and might be
the sort of person who unites the party
he was in charge of the National Health
Service for five and a half years that
made him a lot of enemies of course in
the public sector unions but it shows an
extraordinary grit and power and
determination
he's a remainer who's become a lever he
has appeal right across the party and
here's the appeal of being a safe pair
of hands
however the levers don't trust him
because they think he's a bit too
slippery and he's not a person to run a
very charismatic campaign he'd be a much
better campaign than to resume wars but
he doesn't get the excitement in
politics very much
Sajid Javid is another party unity
candidate and a big beast he's Home
Secretary at the moment as far as a
Muslim he was bus driver and Sajid would
be the first Muslim background Prime
Minister that would enable the
Conservative Party to other claim over
the first party to have a Jew as prime
minister in Disraeli we were the first
party to have a woman as Prime Minister
now were the first person have someone
with their secularized Muslim as Prime
Minister that sniffs whoa anything for a
party to be able to claim the problem
with Sajid is a bit boring he's a bit of
a technocrat he looks more like a number
two than a number one we've talked a lot
about the brexit ears who want to get
one of their own candidates in but we
have to remember that the left of the
party the remainer
will also have quite strong candidates
and probably the leader amongst them is
amber rod she's very popular within the
party she has a sort of jolly hot hockey
sticks head girl persona which goes to
him very well with a lot of members but
she has disadvantages being a remainer
is a disadvantage in the party that's
dominated by bricks and tears and she
had to leave her job as Home Secretary
because of miss handling the Windrush
scandal but her support will
nevertheless be very very important
having amber Rudd as it as it were a
deputy prime minister to a Leever prime
minister would be an interesting and
powerful ticket
this could be one of the most important
leadership struggles the Conservative
Party has faced for a long time and we
could easily have a candidate who
emerges from this who will take the
Conservative Party in a very nationalist
populist
direction rather similar to Trump or we
could have a managerial candidate who
tries to clear up the mess act as a
steady pair of hands and reintroduces
the old tradition of a very managerial
consensual one nation conservativism